etwas klappt herz bekommen bayern neuen
video ich bin zwar immer noch ein
bisschen krank aber ich habe es mir
nicht nehmen lassen heute ein video für
euch zu produzieren
ich habe dabei meinen lieben bruder der
war ja auch schon länger nicht mehr
dabei kannst ja mal an die ganzen gehe
ich vielleicht noch nicht kennen sagen
wie du heißt wir haben uns gedacht wir
müssen auf jeden fall wieder ein video
zusammen drehen um und ja wir haben uns
natürlich etwas krass heftig kreatives
für euch einfallen lassen
und zwar habe ich letztens irgendwann
mal von einer zuschauerin so bien
busalski was immer ich kann ihnen jetzt
sagen wie die gis moment danke anstand
ek umso sie gläubig auf jeden fall habe
ich von denen sowie puzzles bekommen und
beim puzzle sind einfach so irgendwelche
komischen wie heißen die das sind auf
jeden fall irgendwie so komische boden
die schmecken entweder gut oder wie
schlecht die scheiße also ich kann euch
mal kurz ein paar namen vorlesen zum
beispiel was wir hier zum beispiel
stinkende socken limone
verrottetes zahnpasta und so was alles
oder halt auf lecker und ja wir werden
jetzt abwechseln davon einer probieren
und muss seitdem geschmack erwarten also
wir geben uns abwechselnd immer eine
bohne halt vier runden so und der andere
muss man halt immer den geschmack
erraten
entweder es schmeckt halt scheiße oder
schmeckt halt gut es ja auch egal soll
ja auch ein bisschen witzig sein und wer
dann halt öfter das richtig erraten hat
hat gewonnen
und der verlierer kriegt eine wirklich
heftige bestrafung soweit ich das jetzt
ermitteln können also ich hab selber
noch nie ausprobiert aber ist er auf
youtube derzeit vor allem hype dieses
mit dem gildhoff den rücken
und ja das hat mich so ein bisschen dazu
anregt du hast wirklich so weh weil sich
alle jetzt machen die rasten aber
vollkommen aus deswegen würde ich sagen
wir machen das auch und ja wir wollen
gar nicht lange lagern fragen direkt an
die leute runde nummer eins bodies
karamell kokosnuss oder der cocoon es
steckt voller karamell
das wären wieder baby windeln oder kokos
und zweck von gut heißt es auch bis
bereinigung zu nehmen
guck in die kamera
war das richtig dass ja sogar ich weiß
anhand des gewusst was es ist ich habe
das schon mal gegessen früher aber ich
muss das in jubeln was weiß was ist weiß
nicht was ist also nie gegessen was
runtergeschluckt
sie sagen das war einfach hundefutter
immer noch 0 0
sharp hat das 100 euro basis eklig
alters stinkende socken heißt richtig
okay leute 11
frankfurt
was war das stinkende socken sicher
heißt du also leute zwischenstand 1 zu 1
auge blut gibt es eine dvd als richtig
scheiße express berichtet wäre das nicht
schlecht das heim karamell oder so grün
wie mona 22
so leute jetzt steht es 2 2 das ding ist
er hat noch eine bohne offen deswegen er
kann das jetzt gewinnen
was hatten wir dann noch gar nicht
kokosnuss das hat sich doch auch
darunter
das war scheiße cocos dass es richtig
war doch gut okay leute dann würde ich
mal sagen auch wenn ich dumm bin keine
ahnung warum ich das mache
so leute jetzt kommt die bestrafung der
xcom eier
sicher also erstmal so erfolgte weil ein
bisschen mehr dass man nicht sieht sagt
er 32 13 sowie tut das jetzt nicht wahr
dass feste schreibt mir gerade die
kommentare ob das im vergleich zu
anderen feste oder nicht weil ist hat
jetzt also es war voll okay so ok wat
mache einmal so auf aber auch hier macht
macht mal einen vereinfachten
junge das tut echt weh wird das rot im
land vor ort jetzt nicht gedacht also
wenn man das aufs t-shirt macht dann
geht es wirklich voll klar das ist so
als keine ahnung wird man mit so einem
kleinen bank darauf von aber wenn man
das kann ich verstehen aber es machen ja
auch viele leute einfach auf t shirt und
übertreiben darf all das ist man jetzt
nicht einmal bei dir dadurch von 332
ich weiß nicht warum mir das gerade
gemacht haben aber wir haben es einfach
gemacht und wissen was sagen willst
vielleicht während für den instagram
channel machen will zur werbung machen
willst du werbung machen mir auch bei
den zugaben folgen wenn ihr wollt ich
heiße da berlin punkte plans kurz ein
also wenn ihr mal sehen was er für
hübsche fotos post vom 1
dann könnt ihr gerne folgen ja leid wenn
man eigentlich was drüber nachdenken
über diese videos mit diesem gürtel
sowohl ist da der sinn gleich ich frage
mich gerade auch so warum machen desto
weiße so ok ist es witzig und
unterhaltsam aber irgendwie ist ja
keinen sinn hinter für nicht ist doch
scheißegal das passiert im video
wenn es euch gefallen hat platz nach
oben da und am jahr check in bei
instagram ab könnte erfolgen oder so für
das nächste video von uns bei ihnen
könnte beschreiben was ihr von uns sehen
wollt oder so dann machen wir das
eventuell das nächste wiederkommt
sonntag online hat wetterte cher
besonders sagen
peace